it's taken retirement from Athletics for
this Olympian to open up on a deception
and betrayal by a friend that unraveled
his career he was using the apartment
that I was living at to like produce
crack cocaine to then sell on in 2020
this is what police found was stashed
unknowingly Leon Reed maintains by a
friend subletting his home
it was more of just
me their training for the Olympics and
my friend come around doing work I would
go out training come back he was
convicted of allowing his flat to be
used for the production of cocaine and
receiving payment in order to carry out
community service
he had gained status sponsors and
successes with bronze for Northern
Ireland at the 2018 Commonwealth Games
he was preparing for a first Olympics
and he was selected by Island for the
Tokyo games in 2021 while awaiting trial
reaching a 200 meters semi-finals but he
was deemed a security Risk by
Commonwealth Games organizers banned
from competing at Birmingham 2022 people
find it implausible you couldn't realize
your flat was being used for the
production of crack cocaine I did rent
my apartment to him and obviously I
learned from the lesson it was too
nonchalant about the whole situation I
thought I was doing a friend a favor
that this will destroy your Athletics
career losing sponsors yeah destroy my
career and also my sort of reputation
that I built up earnings were lost debt
grew with his first child born a month
ago Reed realized her career harmed by a
criminal conviction had to end I've been
sort of like living this nightmare so
for me to be able to clear the air and
actually get some fresh start then but
that's more important than me getting
angry over someone who's doing 24 years
in prison
chasing income now rather than medals
Leon Reed feels his life is back on
track Rob Harris Sky News Worthing